apenas tiene 16 años y nunca pierden la
oportunidad de rendir homenaje a los
veteranos de
me recuerda a mis abuelos
en la guerra que estuvo en berlín pero
bueno
la memoria es importante para todos
hace dos años elisabetta y dmitri se
unieron a ayudarme a un movimiento
patriótico creado hace seis años por el
ministerio de defensa
[Música]
el programa es bien teniendo armas
lecciones de historia preparación para
ataques químicos y marchas
una formación militar que se puede
seguir a partir de los 8 años
me volví más maduro más disciplinado
hice muchos amigos en moscú y en otros
lugares
me volvió a solidario realmente me hacía
falta
soy más responsabilidad nada aprendí a
entender algo más
más tarde sueña con convertirse en
piloto de la fuerza aérea quiere ser
bombero hijos de policías no ingenieros
dicen que no les interesan las noticias
en cuanto a ucrania
y sinceramente es algo de lo que no
hablamos
lo sabemos y nos bases
en las noticias es suficiente
a mí personalmente no me interesa he
oído hablar de ello pero eso es todo
como ellos más de un millón de pequeños
soldados se han unido a las filas de iun
arme up un compromiso que afecta a todas
las generaciones
a 70 km en la campaña moscovita
alexander es un working de 61 años
colecciona armas de la segunda guerra
mundial
este es el rifle automático ruso papá
que si un apapacho nos ayudó mucho en el
frente
yo no había nacido entonces tú
pero gracias a estas armas es como si
hubiera estado allí
explotar fiestas
cada 9 de mayo este empresario celebra
la victoria sobre la alemania nazi
disfrazado y con su familia
[Música]
cada ciudadano debe ser un patriota y
transmitirlo de generación en generación
es esencial
aquí se mantiene vivo el recuerdo de los
familiares que partieron a luchar oa
cuidar a los heridos
los niños saben que esa es su desagüe
las
eran tres amigas eran enfermeras o
médicas del ejército
este es mi abuelo nicolai pétrovich
conducía un camión cohete katiusha
tardamos 4 años en cruzar este camino
desde moscú a berlín como no estar
orgulloso de ello como dejarlo de lado y
olvidarlo
como muchos rusos los un working están
preocupados por sus familiares en
ucrania la operación especial lo sacudió
profundamente lo siento por los soldados
ucranianos pero también por los nuestros
y no quiero ver esta guerra entre dos
países hermanos
pero no podemos volver atrás es
demasiado tarde pero me siento muy
triste por ello
cuando empezaron estos acontecimientos
militares lloré durante un mes todos los
días dorada
sin adherirse a la acción de vladimir
putin implicarse en la política los un
working son sin embargo patriotas
enamorados de una rusia valientemente
defendida por sus antepasados
varios key
las plantas berlín